So, I would like to start by telling
you the story of a woman
who died in Nevada in last August.
Her death has brought the discussion
of antibiotics resistance
to the news once again.
Basically, she traveled to India
and while she was there,
she broke her right leg.
And then when she returned to the US,
she went to the hospital
to treat her leg injury
and while she was doing some exams,
the doctors discovered she was with
an infection in her leg and hip bones.
But the doctors also determined that
no amount of antibiotics
would be enough to save her life
because she was infected
with multiresistant bacteria.
They were immune to all
the drugs they had.
So there was nothing
they could do to help her.
I would love to tell you
this is an unusual case or an exception,
that antibiotics can treat
the bacterial infections we have today,
but actually, that's no longer true.
Do you have any idea of how many
people die each year
due to this kind of infection?
700,000 more or less.
That might not seem so much when compared
to the 6.4 million deaths caused by stroke
or even the 8.76 million deaths
caused by heart disease.
However, the predictions
show that by 2050,
resistant bacteria will kill around
10 million people a year
if nothing is done to stop them,
which means that stories like the one
I told you will become more common
than stories of people dying
of stroke, heart disease, or cancer.
If we think that around 60 million
people died in World War II
during the six years the war lasted,
it will be the same number of deaths
per year as World War II.
That means the same number of casualties
of our history's deadliest conflict.
We thought antibiotics would forever
protect us from bacteria, right?
But the current situation
is showing us that's wrong.
So as I told you,
we are facing a war against bacteria,
but who are the characters in this war?
So we can compare the harmful bacteria
to an enemy army,
our immune cells
to the soldiers of our army,
and antibiotics to the weapons of our army
in this crazy battle.
If you are in an actual war,
do you think it is clever to keep
constantly attacking your enemy
using the same weapons and strategies?
No, right?
Of course not, because you make it
easier for your opponents to defeat you,
They can analyze your attack methods,
build up defenses,
and then attack you back
with the advantages on their side.
And now you might be thinking,
"But that's quite predictable, isn't it?
We can't have been so naive to do that."
And the answer is, yes, we were.
Bacteria have been doing this analysis
for more than 70 years,
eventually discovering
the resistance genes,
which is a way they found to protect
themselves from our antibiotics,
and this is how this happens.
Imagine you have a person
that is with an infection in their guts.
And there's the bacteria colony
that's making this infection.
And in this colony, one bacterium
is resistant to antibiotics' effects.
Then the person takes the antibiotics,
and as they get in contact
with the colony,
the regular bacteria starts to die,
but the resistant one doesn't.
And now it finds itself with the whole
space and all the nutrients for itself
and then it starts to grow
and grow and grow,
and in the end, we have another colony
of now-resistant bacteria.
So as you can see, antibiotics sometimes
don't solve our problem
because they don't kill the bacteria.
They instead select the resistant ones,
and this is how antibiotics excessive use
becomes a problem
because the more we use them,
the more we increase the chances of ending
up selecting resistant bacteria.
And to make matters worse,
resistant bacteria can share
the resistant genes,
which is that circular DNA there,
with other bacteria that were
previously not resistant,
allowing not only new bacteria
to become resistant
but also to become resistant
to other types of drugs,
because one resistant gene is
effective against one kind of antibiotic.
And they do this process
in a very simple way,
much like a friend that comes
close to you,
you give him or her a present, a gift,
and then they leave.
That's it.
So, there you have one bacterium
that has the resistant gene
and another that doesn't.
So they get very close together,
they share their inner parts.
The resistant bacteria makes a copy
of that gene,
gives it to the other,
and then they split
and now both are resistant.
And since bacteria have been doing
this process since 1945
when the first resistant bacteria
were found,
today there are certain kinds of bacteria
that are immune to almost all,
or even all, antibiotics we have
because they have found
all the ingredients
for this global resistance recipe,
which means there's no cure for them.
We use antibiotics to make animals
get fat faster
so we can slay them and sell their meat,
to protect plants
from agricultural plagues,
people self-medicate in many,
many countries
and even doctors sometimes make mistakes
and prescribe antibiotics
for diseases they can't treat.
We can't do these things anymore in the
pace we have been doing in the last years
if we still want antibiotics protection.
Alexander Fleming received his Nobel Award
for discovering penicillin,
the first antibiotic.
He warned us about the consequences
of using antibiotics excessively,
advice that was ignored
by the pharmaceutical industry.
According to him,
"The thoughtless person playing
with penicillin treatment
is morally responsible
for the death of a man
who succumbs
to a penicillin-resistant organism."
There is another problem,
which is the consequences
of these drugs in our bodies.
So, antibiotics are drugs
that are made to kill bacteria,
making no distinction between the bacteria
that are harmful or helpful to us.
Our bodies are a great
environment for bacteria.
Believe it or not, your body has ten times
more bacteria cells than human cells.
There are certain bacteria that live
in our guts that are so important to us
that we could not live without them.
They could be compared to the people
in this microscopic war
helping us, the nation,
and our immune cells, the soldiers,
to face this war.
They help us in digestion
to absorb essential nutrients
they fight harmful microorganisms,
and they also help us recover from illness
because they stimulate our immune system
to produce immune cells, or more soldiers.
When we take antibiotics, we are removing
part of these natural defenses
which makes us feel even weaker,
and although there are ways to make up
for the damage caused
by antibiotics in our gut flora,
few people take the time to make
the proper supplementation of probiotics,
or these helpful bacteria,
by eating cheese, yogurt,
or probiotic capsules.
Therefore we need to find new weapons and
strategies to turn the tide in this war.
And so the possible solutions are
the development of new drugs,
not only new antibiotics,
new and different antibiotics,
but new vaccines as well,
improving sanitation conditions,
cutting off the use of antibiotics
in livestock and agriculture,
and start using antibiotics
wisely and consciously,
aware of the consequences
that it can cause to us.
And the last one,
and most important of all,
make other people aware, as well.
As we can't just go to a lab and
create a new drug to solve the problem,
we must help the way we can:
washing our hands,
wearing warm clothes during the winter,
eating fruits and vegetables,
basically everything our mothers
have told us to do so many times
in order to prevent illness,
it's very important, too.
Share this information.
Make people aware.
Explain why we should stop
using antibiotics excessively.
Antibiotics are such a valuable tool
and we rely on them for so many things.
We can't just lose them because
of our irresponsibility.
The future is in our hands now.
We can either hold it,
or let it fall between our fingers
Let's make the right choice.
Thank you.